j'accueille maintenant l'ex patron de
l'organisme de contrôle de la télévision
en france
genre si hervé bourges
l'ex patron du csa bonsoir monsieur le
président patron du c'est ça du tout
président reste et pourquoi ça le vrai
et avait bougé si pas bon
lequel d'ailleurs ville bouge bien mais
bon je m'en sois rebond sur fond noir
passe comme ça toute la soirée ça va
être difficile a difficilement
produisirent bien président bonsoir
bonsoir
pierrick alors on vous appelle on vous a
beaucoup appelé le roi bourges
moi je vous ai appelé omar bongo dans tv
sd m'en voulez pas un non pas du tout
pas du tout je vais te faisait régner
sur tf1 sur france 2 sur france 3 sur le
csa ont passé à l'entente brocardé en
dix ans un tiers mondiste deux tiers
monde a en fait pas tellement au monde 1
ouais j'ai le monde
en plus c'est la première fois je vous
vois sens sans cravate
oui j'ai voulu vous imitez vous étiez
comme ça au début c'est vrai que j'étais
beaucoup moins mentionné depuis bas vous
avez un prix delecolle beaux costumes
regard de votre tâche de ketchup
oui ah oui oui c'est ça le hic c'est que
le vrai j'ai démasqué fantômas non mais
je trouve je trouve une chose je trouve
que ça vous donne un look et vous étiez
à témoignage chrétien dans le temps il
ya très longtemps
ça vous donne un peu un look prêtre
ouvrier mais c'est bien hervé vous vexez
pas c'est bien les chalets le plus bas
non c'est donc voilà bien alors on va
parler on va parler de jeu on continue
avec les surnoms la presse d'extrême
droite vous avez baptisé mohamed ouahmed
bourges voilà l'avis rejoint benbella
après l'indépendance de l'algérie
alors on va voir on va essayer de voir
ensemble ce soir ce qu'il en est
vraiment de toutes ces histoires qui
circulent sur vous
on y perd pas de temps et revêtent a vu
serge bien alors vous êtes d'une famille
bretonne de rennes catholique bien
pensante bourgeoise plutôt à droite au
départ un nous le nom oui 12 non
effectivement quand vous étiez jeune je
voulais être comédien et vous étiez un
assez précoce comédiens parce qu'un jour
étiez très jeune vous avez été effrayé
par un bourdon et vous avez crié si fort
qu'on vous a amené à 60 kilomètres de là
à bourges pour vous opéré d'une
appendicite fallait quand même que j'ai
pas osé dire à ma mère que j'avais peur
d'un bourdon je lui dis j'ai mal au
ventre et puis je me suis retrouvé sur
la table d'opération mais voilà et on
vous enlevez l'appendicite ça vous
apprendra vous aviez déjà un certain
sens de la de la comédie mais aussi le
sens de la deûle honneur parce que
pendant la guerre envoyé des troupes
allemandes défiler dans la rue si très
jeune que les stadiers je suis né en 33
en février c'est en quoi l omc l'aja
tout 7 8 ans oui c'est ça hé hé hé vous
cracher par terre h oui je crois que me
pop par inconscience beaucoup plus que
par courage vous savez un stage là je
crache mamère 9 mai une paire de claques
comme disons mais attention tu vas nous
on va avoir des problèmes et voilà oui
parce que la france ait des pétainistes
à l'époque faut quand même pas l'oublier
un samassa m'a pris beaucoup de choses
je vais sur la lâcheté des gens et sur
le fait qu a finalement peu de gens dans
la vie qui dans des situations très
dures très difficile je pense à ça je
pense à la 40
je pense à la guerre d'algérie où il ya
des gens qui ont résisté
bon à la torture en algérie un bon moi
je pense à d'autres qui dans d'autres
circonstances on dit non je pense même
dans les situations très simple j'étais
président tf1 de france 2 france 3
qu'est ce que j'avais comme ami quand
j'étais président oui j'ai découvert
tout à coup le jour où je partais pas
qu'il y en avait plus beaucoup mais ça
ça m'a appris que dans la vie il ya 99%
de lâches et puis il ya un type oui là
là vous avez été là vous avez vraiment
pris conscience de la nature humaine
c'est la libération
et quand vous voyez tous ces ex collabos
qui d'un seul coup deviennent des
premiers joueurs qui vous qui aimez rire
et des trucs ces fissures le bras qui
vont tondre des femmes qui les mettra à
la vindicte les livre à la vindicte
publique soit un duel sont battues elles
sont parce qu'elle avait couché avec des
allemands s'était pas bien sans doute
mais voilà et j'ai découvert des gens et
même des voisins qui étaient les types
qui était toujours en train de chanter
maréchal nous voilà qui sont des coûts
est résistant ben ça dans la vie vous
savez c'est à dire je le son rauque
honte soit sur îles salomon chéri leçons
alors vous étiez pas l'adolescent très
docile en 4e ou fugué avec une
basketteuse
oui c'est vrai les particules c'est vrai
on est belle puisque les réelles match
féminin elle match berens et puis on a
on est on est resté je me suis fait
mettre à la porte de malley j'ai mon
père m'a dit tu seras puni baby schumi
chez les jésuites et vous dis
d'emballant des jésuites ils m'ont
appris la liberté tout à fait
bizarrement et ben ils m'ont appris à
penser par moi même j'étais chez les
curés chez les jésuites je m'imaginais
pas que ce serait comme ça hein
ils ont par exemple à midi
on nous lisait les journaux salé
l'humanité au figaro voyez c'est quand
même bon les gens se faisaient leurs
propres idées oui j'irai chez les
jésuites vous vous commencez à faire du
théâtre parce que oui location c'est
vrai mais oui voilà et avec jean becker
oui j'en ai encore un film là michel le
ciel robin michel robin la
comédie-française un vieux copain à moi
qui jour sur le mans le bourgeois
gentilhomme l'e10 française et qui
société à la commune i française et qui
jouent avec moi au théâtre vous allez
jouer tout molière et vous dites à votre
père je veux être comédien hors pair il
vous dit comédiens ça se fait pas il
faut que tu aies une situation il m'a
dit c'est pas une situation d'être
comédien oui c'est vraiment unique
cette compagnie bon c'est pareil que je
remarque c'est finalement j'ai été
obligé de suivre ma famille ma mère m'a
dit t'as qu'à faire du journalisme c'est
la même chose pour très bien alors j'ai
fait l'école supérieure de journalisme
de lille école que vous dirigerez par la
suite donc vous êtes toujours président
est fier de vous sortez majeur de la
promo et quand on sort major de la promo
de cette école on peut choisir de
l'enchère leur antre au figaro rentrer
au figaro il ya cinquante trois anciens
de l'école au final oui et vous vous
dites non non c'est michel bassi qui va
au figaro et vous vous allez à
témoignages sont intéressants kg et moi
je retiens faut pas trop regarder le
côté curé un journal très engagé contre
la guerre d'algérie contre x ali qui
était pour le pour la décolonisation etc
et je fais la mise en page j'écris aussi
des éditoriaux je me souviens que j'ai
écrit
alors là vous évite des éditoriaux pour
faut reconnaître c'était très 156 à
haïti contre l'intervention des
soviétiques des sur angry la fameuse
affaire de budapest où les chars russes
en prêt dans budapest
vous vous élevez contre l'intervention
franco anglaise à suez qu'il faut savoir
c'est comme un cerf à nationaliser le
canal de suez les anglais les français
on voulait intervenir nous élever contre
ça et surtout vous élever contre la
capture des leaders du fln parpaings par
la france dont le leader du fln à l'est
de rabat à tunis en avions et l'armée
française des à les attraper
c'est un acte de piraterie
internationale c'est le premier acte de
piraterie internationale si on en parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui on dit
des pirates scandaleux et rades c'est
nous qui avons commis le 1er la france
quel effet ça c'était le roi mohamed 5
qui avait traité la gérante prêté son
avion etc
ça crée d'ailleurs les troupes terrible
au maroc et l'avion a été interceptée
moi je me suis élevé contre ça bien
évidemment voilà ce qui était assez
étonnant finalement dans votre histoire
avait beau c'est que vous vous êtes
contre la guerre d'algérie vous avez 2
contre le colonialisme et malgré tout
vous allez faire l'armée en algérie oui
oui je suis pas un déserteur je suis
vous n'êtes pas un version je comprends
que des gens qui soient comme ça et en
action très courageuse moi je vais pas
été j'ai fait mon service et 30 mois je
traite 30 mois en algérie comme deuxième
classe parce qu'on a on m'a dit vous
êtes quelqu'un qui avait pris des
positions contre la guerre d'algérie la
sécurité militaire vous affichez pas
question de faire l'école des officiers
ouais je me suis retrouvé 2e classe qui
m'a permis de me retrouver avec des
camarades qui savaient pas lire et
écrire c'est moi qui écrivais lors la
vessie écrivain public faisait monter
des pièces montées antigone de sophocle
dans les ruines romaines de djeddah
il y avait ce talent et il y avait 3000
hommes j'ai expliqué le mythe de
d'antigone et le fait que tout n'est pas
permis dans la vie et que ce qui compte
c'est la conscience mais je crois pas
qu'ils aient compris en jeu alors quand
vous rentrez en france vous voulez
rentrer au monde et ses lacs michelez
vous demande de vous occuper
je raconte ça parce que c'est très
important c'est de votre image on a
beaucoup souffert ça que vous occupez
des leaders du fln qui sont emprisonnés
en france ils ont été donc à raisonner
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
et souvent c'est vrai l'image que vous
avez eue c'est l'image de quelqu'un qui
avait vraiment travailler directement
pour le fln qui était un porteur de
valises du réseau jeanson pour les
élèves est en fait pas du tout c'est
l'état français qui me demande si le
gouvernement français qui vous dit comme
vous connaissiez bien l'algérie j'étais
anti colonialiste dit allez vous occuper
des leaders du fn
je me suis occupé notamment du transfert
de
une belle aït ahmed khider boudia ebita
de l'île d'aix à turcan c'est moi qui
m'en suis occupé qu'ils aient trouvé le
lieu j'avais 25 ans et j'ai fait c'est
là où m'est venue un petit peu un
certain goût du pouvoir si vous voulez
parce que je me suis rendu compte qu'à
25 ans j'avais devant moi des vieux
magistrat de 60 ans qui était directeur
de mission financier et directeur des
grâces directeur de et qui était là
devant la langue du cabinet en dix ans
mais oui qu'est ce qu'on doit faire et
c'est alors simplement il demander qui
est des notes écrites
voilà et à ce moment là où 1962 à
l'indépendance algérienne ben bella vous
demande de venir construire avec lui la
nouvelle république algérienne
oui vous êtes numéro trois du cabinet de
la mairie 3g oui oui il travaillait avec
bouteflika qui est maintenant présent la
république à l'algérie il vous était
flic à bouteflika demis et des sports il
m'a demandé des directeurs de la
jeunesse éducation populaire s était
gonflé de demander ça un français à
l'époque de alors moi j'ai des relations
très difficiles
du côté français on disait qu'est ce que
c'est que ce type il a trahi son pays il
est parti travailler avec les algériens
qui ont etc qui ont monza n'est pas
alors indépendance contre la france puis
du côté algérien je suppose que certains
ont dû dire qu'est ce que c'est que
cette barbe rousse qui vient nous aider
les états et en fait ça s'est très bien
passé pour moi jusqu'en 1967 jusqu'à ce
que boumédiène remplace benbella oui et
là vous êtes catalogué opposants s'est
arrêté et là quand même
on va voir une certaine grandeur d'âme
parce que hervé bourges est arrêté à 6
heures du matin l'heure du laitier a
menotté dans le dos les yeux bandés en
vous emmène arrête on vous emmène dans
une prison on vous met un saut en faire
sur la tête et on tape un coup de barre
sur le saut en longueur
oui ça fait du bruit et ça résonne fort
dans l'année c'est quand même et c'est
pas terrible c'est j'ai eu pire la
gégène c'était pire
mais à ce moment là vous allez me
détester c'est quand même fou vous qui
le remettra dès que vous quittez votre
pays la france
oui vous avez géré vous aider ben bella
a construit la république algérienne
changement de régime il vous arrête et
vous torture oui mais non moi ça m'a
prévenue si jamais l'on attendait à un
moment je me suis fait battre
hervé bourges peut pas être aussi bons
ce que de dire ah bon c'est gens là me
tape sur la tête je suis pas bon mais je
suis quelqu'un d'abord qui ne déteste
pas les gens qui ensuite comprend les
situations et qui me dit l'humanité elle
est comme ça allait
les tortionnaires ont quitté le pays et
puis il ya de nouveaux tortionnaires qui
ont été les types qui ont été torturés
c'était dans une cgt dans une cellule où
il était marqué vive le fln l'algérie
vaincra c'était l'équipe du fln qui
était arrêté par les paras français qui
étaient torturés à cet endroit
ben ça continue est d'accord ce qui m'a
donné une vision de la vie
je dirais plutôt pessimiste car je
suivais sinistre actif/actif oui parce
que je me dis que il faut pas seulement
espérer pour entreprendre parce que
sinon c'est vrai la peine de faire
quoique ce soir et un l'humanité est
comme ça et tous ceux qui sont là comme
moi comme nous comme une touche savaient
où trouver devant un devant demain
devant des gens qui vous disent où nous
tu fais ça où tu es
ben vous ferez ce que les gens qui ont
la force vous demanderont de faire et
puis on a un parmi vous de quiron moi je
marche pas moi je suis là j'ai pas vous
j'en ai pas voulu du tout à ce moment là
aux algériens j'ai 18 ans je dois dire
que le premier à avoir protesté
immédiatement c'est bouteflika le
cardinal duval à alger est justement le
candidat je vais garder un budget vous a
aidé et le membre un jeune membre du
cabinet de georges pompidou qui
s'appelait jacques chirac
oui qui vous a aidé au retour tout à
fait donc vous sortez quand vous rentrez
en france vous refusé de s'exprimer là
dessus vous dites je ne veux pas
provoquer l algérien de là dessus j'ai
pas voulu
oui le vieux père que les gens disent il
a que ce qu'ils méritent quoi d'à côté
bouillonner l'état qui disait bien fait
pour lui ça lui a fallu apprendre à
aller marcher avec ces [ __ ] un
très bon et puis de l'autre côté des
gens du côté algérien nos rues d'ibb
voilà le type il est allé là-bas pour
raconter de tout ce qui lui est arrivé
j'ai pas voulu
j'ai pas voulu j'ai écrit dans mon livre
on bouteflika a reçu mon livre il écrit
à l'arrêt c'est comment on fait pardon
est ce que j'aimerais comme fait ça
comme ça on sent quand même un peu la
famille bourgeoise de rennes là quand
même
alors on s'est connus nous faut le dire
on s'est connus en 85 c'est vous qui
m'avez fait commencer la télévision est
ce que vous avez fait que pascal josèphe
catherine barma et marie france brière
donc rien chez vous je vous le dis c'est
que vous n'oubliez jamais ce qui au
départ vous aider et puis qu'il continue
de travailler avec vous comme catherine
barma bravo
non